First of all,
you unite your mind,
you're thinking,
let's say with your emotions.
So that makes one thing
instead of two fighting things.
Okay,
that's a good one.
And then the next conjunction he talked
about was it isn't enough to unite your
mind and your emotions.
And he thought about that as a
male female pairing symbolically.
That's how it would manifest
itself sometimes in dreams.
So you take the masculine
element and the feminine element,
the the thinking and
the emotion unite those.
And that makes you more like one thing.
Okay.
And now all of a sudden that's
represented as symbolically mail.
That one thing and it unites with
something else that's now represented
symbolically,
seven female,
that's the body.
So you take the mind,
emotion integration and
integrate that in your body.
So what does that mean?
You act it out instead of just thinking.
So there's this
philosophical idea called a,
now I'm going to forget what it's called.
It's a contradiction in action.
There's actually a technical term for it,
but that's when you think
and believe something,
but you're,
but you don't act it out.
And so that means there is a dissociation
in you somehow between your abstract
representations and what
you manifest in action.
While that's another form of discontinuity
that isn't doing you any good.
You know the driver's going one way and
the cars going the other and you won't
even be able to understand
yourself if you do that.
But even more,
you're not putting your principles
into practice so you're disassociated.
You're being is dissociated.
So once you get your mind and
your emotions working together,
then the next thing to do is
to act that out consistently.
So that was the second conjunction
as far as young was concerned.
And then the third one was,
this is the tough one and this is the
one that's related to phenomenology.
You erase the distinction
between yourself and the world.
Okay,
that's a tough one.
So imagine you're dealing
with someone who's hoarding.
Now,
people who are hoarding are often older
or neurologically damaged or they have
obsessive compulsive disorder.
But then you walk into their house and
there's like 10,000 things in their
house.
There's,
there's,
there's maybe a hundred boxes and you
open up a box and in the box there's some
pens and some old passports and some
checks and their collection of silver
dollars and some hypodermic
needles and some Dustin,
you know,
a dead mouse and,
and,
and there's boxes and boxes and
boxes is like that in the house.
It's absolute chaos in
their absolute chaos,
not ordered chaos.
And then you think is that
their houses that they're being,
is that their mind and answer
is there's no difference.
There's no difference.
So,
you know,
I could say,
well,
if you want to organize your psyche,
you could start by organizing your
room if they've thought would be easier
because maybe you're a more concrete
person and you need something concrete to
do.
So you go clean up under your bed and
you make your bed and you organize the
papers on your desk and you think,
well,
just exactly what are you organizing?
Are you organizing the objective
world or are you objecting your field?
Are you organizing your field of being
like your field of total experience?
And young believed that.
And I think that there's a Buddhist
doctrine that sort of nested in there that
at the highest level of
psychological integration,
there's no difference between
you and what you experience.
Now you think,
well,
I can't control everything I experienced,
but that's no objection because
you can't control yourself anyway.
So the mere fact that you can't extend
control over everything you experience is
no argument against the idea that you
should still treat that as an extension of
yourself.
So you can say,
well,
let's say you have a long standing
feud with your brother while sat a
psychological problem.
Is that him?
Is it a problem in the objective world?
Or is,
is it a problem in your field of being?
And it's very useful to think
that way because you might ask,
what could you do to improve yourself?
Well,
let's step one step backwards.
The first question might be,
why should you even
bother improving yourself?
And I think the answer to
that is something like,
so you don't suffer any more
stupidly than you have to.
And maybe so others don't have to either.
It's something like that,
you know,
like there's a real injunction
at the bottom of it.
It's not some casual self-help doctrine.
It's that if you don't
organize yourself properly,
you'll pay for it and in a big way.
And so will the people around
you now and you could say,
well I don't care about that,
but that's actually not true.
You actually do care about
that because if you're in pain,
you will care about it.
And so you do care about it.
Even if it's just that negative way,
you know,
it's very rare that you can find someone
who's in excruciating pain who would
ever say,
well,
it would be no better if I was out of
this sort of pain is one of those things
that brings the idea that it would be
better if it didn't exist along with it.
It's in controvertible so you get your
act together so that there isn't any more
stupid pain around you than necessary.
We'll,
so then the question might be,
well how would you go about
getting your act together?
And the answer to that.
And this is a phenomenological idea too,
it's something like look around for
something that bothers you and see if you
can fix it.
So now you think,
well let's say there,
let's say you go into,
you can do this in a room.
It's quite fun to do it just when
you're sitting in a room like a room,
maybe your bedroom,
you can sit there and just sort
of meditate on it and think,
okay,
if I wanted to spend 10 minutes
making this room better,
what would I have to do?
And you have to ask yourself that,
right?
It's not a command.
It's like our genuine question and things
will pop out in the room that you know
you like there's a stack of papers over
there that's kind of bugging you and you
know that maybe little order there
would be a good thing and you know,
you haven't,
there's some rubbish behind your computer
monitor that you haven't attended to
for like six months.
And the room would be slightly better
if it was a little less dusty and the
cables weren't all
tangled up the same way.
And like if you,
if you allow yourself just to consider
the expanse in which you exist at that
moment,
there'll be all sorts of things that'll
pop out in it that you could just fix.
And you know,
I might say,
well,
if you were coming to
see me for psychotherapy,
this smell,
easiest thing for us to do first would
just be to get you to organize your room.
You think,
well,
is that psychotherapy?
And the answer is,
well,
it depends on how you conceive
the limits of your being.
And I would say start where you can start.
You know,
if,
if something announces itself to you,
which is a strange way
of thinking about it,
as in need of repair
that you could repair,
then hey,
fix it.
You fix a hundred things like that.
Your life will be a lot different.
Now,
I often tell people to fix the things
you repeat every day because people tend
to think of those as trivial,
right?
You get up,
you brush your teeth,
you have your breakfast,
you know,
you have your routines that
you go through every day.
Well though,
those probably constitute
50% of your life.
And people think,
well,
they're mundane,
I don't need to pay attention to them.
It's like,
no,
that's exactly wrong.
The things you do every day,
those are the most important
things you do hands down.
All you have to do is do the arithmetic.
You figure it out right away.
So a hundred adjustments to your broader
domain of being and there's a lot less
rubbish and there's a lot
less rubbish around it,
a lot fewer traps for you to step into.
And so that's in keeping with
Ewing's idea about erasing the dis.
Once you've got your mind
and your emotions together,
and once you're acting that out,
then you can extend what you're willing
to consider yourself and start fixing up
the things that are part
of your broader extent.
Now sometimes you don't
know how to do that.
So you might say,
imagine you're walking down Bloor
street and there's this guy who's like
alcoholic and schizophrenia and has
been on the streets for 10 years.
He sorta stumbled
towards you and you know,
incoherently mutters something.
That's a problem.
And it would be good if you could fix it,
but you haven't got a clue
about how to fix that.
You just walk around that and go
find something that you could fix.
Because if you muck about in that,
not only is it unlikely that
you'll help that person,
it's very likely that
you'll get hurt yourself.
So you know,
just because while you're
experiencing things,
announced themselves as in need of repair,
doesn't mean that it's you right that
in there that should repair them.
You have to have some humility.
You know,
you don't walk up to a helicopter that
isn't working and just start tinkering
away with it.
You,
you have to stay within
your domain of competence.
But most of the time,
if people look at their lives,
you know,
it's very interesting thing to do.
I liked the,
I liked the idea of the room because
you can do that at the drop of a hat.
You know,
we'd go back to where you
live and sit down and think,
okay,
I'm gonna make this place
better for half an hour.
What should I do?
It you have to ask.
And things will just pop up like mad.
And it's partly because your
mind is a very strange thing.
As soon as you give it a name,
a genuine aim,
it'll reconfigure the world
in keeping with that aim,
that that's actually how
you see to begin with.
And so if you said it a task,
especially if you have
to be genuine about it,
which is why you have to bring your
thoughts and emotions together,
and then you have to
get them into your body.
So you're acting consistently,
you have to be genuine about the aim.
But once you aim,
the world will reconfigure
itself around that aim,
which is very strange.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it's technically true.